it's been about 15 months Wow time flies
since we launched a separate section in
the Play Store just for families and
since then we've built a lot more
products and services so for this
audience so I'll share some of those
things with you as well as insights on
what we have sort of gleaned from this
15 months of half staff so families are
very important and strategic audience
and we all know that right and they're
both important and strategic to Google
but also specially to play most of the
families most of us but the world's
population lives in family based
households right and as we can see just
in the US alone the family the device
usage both for smartphones and tablets
is much higher in houses which have
minor children in fact those households
also you know whether families tend to
use their mobile devices a lot more for
purchasing goods and services or playing
games and it is not just the sheer
numbers of families that matter here it
is also how they use technology we've
done a lot of surveys of parents and
kids and in fact overwhelmingly kids say
technology is a part of their life and
it's one of the best parts about being a
kid
and one such kid is Mathias who's a 10
year old in Canada and he loves rubik's
cubes and he's using technology to
create a contraption to help him solve
Rubik's cubes and it's just an example
of how kids and therefore households
that have kids really experience
technology in a different way and that's
why we created experiences just for
families in the Play Store so as I said
last year about 15 months ago we
launched a separate destination on the
Play Store just for families and then in
a major store update we brought that
front and center so you know on the main
store users can just click a parent and
click on that and basically see all the
content for families at the end of last
year we launched a
music plan we're up to six members in a
family can share purchase music for
$14.99 and when you think about stuff
that you want to share with families or
do with families right there's a lot of
sort of you know exploring learning new
things together you know I know for with
my kids I love cooking or traveling you
want to make sharing really easy and
that's why a couple of months ago we
launched the family library and what
this does is allows you as a family
again up to six people to share
purchased apps and games movies TV shows
books with members in your family and
from a developer perspective what this
does for you is it increases your
engagement and reach and for users it
gives them a great experience as a
family on play and one of the best parts
about this is when someone is setting up
that family account they actually put
down a family a credit card as a family
form of payment and as we all know
that's one of the biggest hurdles in
friction points in the purchase flow so
now that they have it in there already
they're more prone to hopefully making
purchases so now let's shift gears we're
talking about you know what's important
to family is what content do families
care about right and in this one of the
you know and then it's all of us were
part of a family you don't think about
one thing I think remains constant no
matter where you are developed world
emerging rich poor rural or urban most
your cap parents want to raise their
kids to be happy productive successful
and how do we help them do that so
anyone know kids who are starting school
now it's the back-to-school season which
you are they going to be graduating from
college quick math here we're 2033
and I guess depending on how many years
of school you know they are but at least
in the u.s. 2033 and we think about what
are they going to be
yes I'll be doctors they'll be
scientists engineers what-have-you but
research shows 60% of those jobs have
not been invented yet so then here's the
conundrum if there are you know jobs
that haven't been invented and
technologies have been created and we
don't even know which problems were
trying to solve how do you have these
kids grow up how do you use technology
to help them be happy productive
successful right so one thing though is
is always good to know in reassuring
with all this uncertainty kids will
always be kids which means they will be
insatiably curious and that is really
helpful as you know they need to be so
as we start thinking about you know as
parents as educators as developers as
you know the whole community how do we
prepare this next generation to for
those challenges and what how can
technology play a role in that
Google Commission's The Economist
Intelligence Unit to do a survey to
understand what are those skills that
those kids will need for those jobs that
don't exist today so I'd love to get
your thoughts
any thoughts on kind of what came up and
but I feel free this is a you want to
make this more interactive and in turn
we can tell I ask a lot of questions
anyone there's no wrong answer Thomas
can I call on you and it also what what
skills would be important for kids to
learn good answer yeah the creativity is
important anyway so you know there are
so interestingly one would think that
yes coding and engineering and you know
so all that we the science isn't all
important and they were there but
business leaders over me said the soft
skills are really important so you know
problem-solving team building
collaboration communication all those
really matter and why it's because even
as technology changes types of works
people do a different and again those
jobs 60 percent of which haven't
invented yet these skills are what you
need to basically crack hard challenges
right work with diverse teams
to solve problems or imagine problems
that don't exist so as developers you
know think about Cree making sure that
the apps and games you build help
instill these you know these skills in
kids more than just it's a math app or
the you know this app helps them with
this particular part of their curriculum
so innovation to give you some examples
of these even at Google innovation we
know is global and as we think about
innovation of the future it's going to
come from a lot of different
perspectives working together that we
have human-to-human collaboration and
there's a lot more kind of human to
smart machine collaboration so at Google
you know we have a diverse stream and
you can see just you know being here we
have people different countries and
cultures and you know different
languages work together but also
collaborate across disciplines so for
example you have the Google lens which
is a contact lens which measures the
blood sugar level in diabetic patients
and in this we have course data
scientists computer engineers but
collaborating with biologists and
neurologists right so any more recent
example is you know phenomenon of
Pokemon go
you've got IP lives and sores and they
are engineers and cartographers all
coming together to create is really
interesting you know different
experience so to do well kids will need
to learn how to collaborate effectively
across all these boundaries and
creativity you know as Thomas mention
also is going to be really important
because creativity actually drives true
invention so think about you know
artificial intelligence for example
where you have in Google photos you can
do a search for you know pictures of
your dog and without having tagged them
all the pictures on which your dog is
present show up because it understands
the dog or the technology in
self-driving cars right Industrial
machines took over blue-collar jobs and
we see computers increasingly taking
over white-collar jobs but there's
something computers won't ever be able
to do which is identify what are the
problems and what things need to be
created and then drive to create them
and that is why helping kids in
creativity in kids is so important
there's a lot of information right at
their fingertips and in fact years ago
kids went to the library and sifted
through encyclopedias and and got the
information now they have in a computer
in their desk then they have it on their
phone they have it on their wrist and
soon they're going to be wearing you
know things which give them information
so critical thinking is really important
to understand with all the Seif
information how do you sift through it
find out what's important and then
actually use that so moving on now a
little bit to kind of our learnings from
you know having a family section and
play and what it takes to achieve
success there so done a lot of research
as I've mentioned with parents and kids
and as you all know there's two main
users of any kids content unlike you
know sort of other other categories so
you got the parents who you make the
download decisions and control the spend
definitely and who also monitor the
usage and I've got kids who are the
ultimate users of that content and we've
seen this distinct split as kids grow
older the parents role changes so when
kids are young you know up to eight
years old or so parents really make the
ultimate decision on what to download
they have the final say they make the
decision they in fact for younger kids
they spend a lot of time with the kids
and you know playing with them that
content but as kids grow older the
interest change and they're you know
they get their their own hobbies their
own friends who give them
recommendations and they have their own
devices and that's where parents role
change is more towards the sort of
monitoring role and sometimes this is
where parents and kids butt heads on
what's appropriate to download so
therefore thinking about parents is
equally if not more important as
thinking about kids so on play we've
noticed parents actually browse a lot
more than your average user typically
people come to Play Store they sort you
know what they want they search for a
download and leave but when parents do
that they actually come and they spend
time browsing looking for stuff that
they think their kid is going to be
interested in they spend a lot of time
doing categorical searches and going
through different categories and also
comparing apps and valuating them to say
is this appropriate for my child and
when they search and browse what do they
look at the three main things that
they've told us they care of our brands
because brands to them denote quality
and it's you know it's appropriate it's
kid-friendly and especially brands that
they've known and loved and so investing
in a brand while expensive definitely
makes sense in the space they also think
about interests like Charles interests
of child likes dinosaurs or plane or
travel and also sometimes formal
learning you know math animals and then
finally they care about their characters
and they care about characters that are
your kids are watching their TV shows
and then no one's interested in but also
even sometimes characters from their
childhood that they want to bring to
that kids and what are the top factors
that there is and use to make that
decision to purchase right so the
million dollar or rather the $2.99
question rather so they've told us these
six things matter a lot to them fun and
engagement is important right and that
makes sense but this also does a nuance
to this because this changes as the kids
age changes when kids are younger
parents are looking more for something
educational and fun but as kids grow old
and they start going to schools parents
recognizing getting a lot of learning
from there so then it becomes more
entertaining and recreational so it
really needs to be a way for them to
relax and not kind of to get stressed
out they also care about it being
age-appropriate right so this is not
just as the content you know doesn't
have profanity or sexual content and all
but is my kid going to be frustrated
because the the activities are too easy
or too hard for them so I really look at
look for that they care about interest
and we've talked about that and this is
where sometimes for older kids their
interests and their parents interest
divert and educational content and this
matters a lot when they're younger
because for younger kids parents
associate any sort of content with being
educational high quality really matters
to them like it needs to be something
that looks professional has been done
nicely and then of course price so how
where do they look to know I mean that's
a lot of huge laundry lists how do they
know that something has this or not the
app listing page and that is why it's
really really
and as you've probably heard a lot of
the stuff we were doing all the tools
Google plays building are geared towards
really helping you guys optimize that
page right so here star rating matters
and star rating of four stars above is
really good and what parents say they do
is when they even in search results they
use the star rating as a way to then
click into and get into a listing page
because they're like wow this seems like
it's high quality and we've seen before
were also you know quality corresponds
commensurately the higher the star
reading it also corresponds to you know
high ravening parents also use the
family badge with the age the age rating
and that they've told us is a really
quick and easy way for them to scan to
see is this trusted inappropriate right
and kid-friendly and also is it
appropriate age appropriate for their
kids so that badge is really important
as you think about what age group you
want to you know you want to put down
for your for your app really think
carefully through what is that
you know what that is because parents
will will use that to determine whether
or not to to download your content title
and description matter
in fact the ends have told us they
actually read the description fully and
I'm probably more than any other
category so make sure very thoughtful
when you're writing that description and
I've said before in other presentations
you know what if you want accolades and
all that's important but really be very
clear up front initially this is what it
is right and then you can you know go
through all the different prizes and all
the app as one and finally icon and
screenshots are very important kids
specially react we've done surveys and
they react to the icon that's one of the
most important things for them and
parents use screenshots to understand
what the user experience will be
remember they're not the ultimate user
and especially for something that
they're not sure off the screenshot tell
tells them very quickly yes there's
something that might make it would like
ratings and reviews you've heard a lot
about you know how important they are in
having a improving your your your
quality of the app and it reflects
reflecting the quality of the app we're
more important in this space family
space than any other because parents you
use these reviews to understand is that
content appropriate have other parents
like this content and it gives them a
sense of whether or not their kid will
like it remember because they're making
a decision not for themselves but for
someone else
so the first typically the first ten
reviews also matter and it also matters
are those reviews from other parents
right because even if it's friends who
don't have kids it's not as important as
someone they don't know but who has a
kid their kids age so they really look
for reviews from other parents and I'd
encourage you guys to make sure that
your users will love your apps leave
reviews up there and take advantage of
place features and reviews that you know
you heard about earlier today and also
at i/o so we talked about how compelling
store listing is and the icon how many
people here have used store listing
experiments by the way how many haven't
but planned to okay well these are
really important you've heard me talk
about probably if you've come to my
presentations review who now does not
launch anything without experimenting
with the icon to see what what works and
then baby first who used you change an
icon so ten percent increase and
installs and the app and some of you
earlier this year may have heard pear
from apps families talk about super
puzzle they noticed when they launched
with the dat dragon down icon wasn't
getting a lot of downloads they weren't
sure why they change to the unicorn and
almost to be immediately revenue and
downloads doubled and I figured out it's
because a lot of moms who are
downloading this and for some reason I
think they they saw women get you know
like the icon for like unicorns and so
then after that they experimented with
using a borderless icon and they're so
installs increase up to five percent
after that so if you're not using this
already I would use you know definitely
think about this but the point I'm
trying to make here is think about your
audience and what they want right if
they're thinking moms are downloading
unicorns matter to them and then test it
so this is where both an art and a
science
so think high quality experience needs
to work on any device that that is used
on and in the kid space
tablets are way more important than in
maybe any other category and in fact I
would say equally if not more important
than phones so younger kids especially
avid tablet users sometimes it's you
know cheaper device it's a hand-me-down
from their parents it's a family device
unlike the phone which is my personal
device and given that a lot of spend of
family apps majority of it comes on
tablets optimizing for tablets and using
our tablet guidelines to make sure that
your that your your you use the full
real estate in your screenshots I'm
using you know as much as you you can to
make sure it works on tablets is
important and then speaking of testing
right you want to make sure that it
works on whatever device as I said
whether the parent or the child making
the decision it needs to you don't want
them to leave you've got this beautiful
contents teaching kids creativity in
collaboration but if it's buggy kids
offical they're going to leave so use
and I know we've talked about this
earlier but use the the firebase test
lab pre-launch report to see does it
work on all the devices supposed to are
the screenshots showing up correctly as
where they are are there any bugs of
vulnerabilities but I want you know sab
down a lot of talking I want you also
for you to hear from developers on what
playful families is meant for them you
play the video pleases the launch of the
family section on Google Play was hugely
positive for story toys I think what it
did was solved the discovery issue for
parents it's really provided a safe
trusted creative space for families to
find new content
my partner guy or annum and I started
baby first with the idea and a passion
to create good educational content for
babies toddlers and their parents when
we learned about family category on the
Google Play Store it was a hundred
percent match to the baby first values
we have seen that parents can easily
find the content they are looking for
we now have 40% more downloads on Google
Play than we do on other platforms you
like that since the launch of the family
section on Google Play our experience
with Android has been completely
transformed we saw huge uplift in
revenues and downloads to Google Play
was now our number one channel it's been
nothing but positive were delighted to
be involved
you
sorry you want to close with so if you
are we talk about a giant design the
family program earlier so if you're
building any content for kids either if
it's purely for kids ie child directed
or it's for mixed audience so adults and
kids both enjoy it make sure can you
join the design for families program
understanding that the guideline so you
need to have a rating of ten or ten plus
from ESRB and also think about the
audience where if it's a purely child
directed app you can't use Google Play
sign-in and if it's for both kids and
adults you can use it would make it
optional for the rest of you if you're
thinking about creating content for poor
poor kids and publishing on the Play
Store definitely download that our
marketing team is done an amazing job
and in you know getting not just
insights that we've learned from on clay
but also insights from other developers
some of which you heard in the video on
best practices that they use okay cool
thank you so much and I'll be around
later if you want to ask any more
questions of those have
you